[Music]
do you guys believe that there is such a
thing as healthy meth yes if you're if
you're asking it like that I don't know
cuz I've heard of a thing called healthy
margaritas and Nadeem is yet to produce
them so I'm a little confusing you out
he said you [ __ ] okay okay okay so I
was I was trying to go to the store
today
right he was like hey as I was leaving
here using it a secret just texted me
he's like hey I'm actually really sick
of margaritas please do not get anything
for it because I don't want to look like
a [ __ ] in front of okay even though I
already asked you first
I'm on airplane mode right now it never
said come on Ellen water you promised
okay it was between me and Steve you're
full of [ __ ] virgin margaritas if
they're that bomb made virgin margaritas
yeah the only thing that would have been
non alcoholic in that margarita would
have been the line oh that's a big
component yeah so big so you just want
lime juice I have a bottle of you
somewhere oh well uh you also needed to
bring a blender because we don't have
one no no bunny oh there's a real man
real margarita teach the Mexican over
ice so it's two parts tequila one part
Cointreau all right
Grand Marnier for one area one part one
part for is ours okay one ounce lime
whatever
two ounces tequila trou it's a liqueur
flavouring its owners flavored yeah what
about the margarita mix you know I put
that in no that's a try class oh really
yeah kind of tequila you then I was
using costume you goes okay yeah that's
late yeah anyway back to this story here
this mess let's talk about math no no no
is this healthy meth just Admiral that
pharmaceutical grade like prescribed
yeah alright that's cocaine healthy
cocaine oh yeah alright well this man in
Colorado
who's 49 years old named Craig was
arrested on suspicion of controlled
substance possession possession of drug
paraphernalia and unlawful distribution
manufacturing and dispensing of a
controlled substance seized which is
sounds like a whole lot of the same
thing 25 years was that well he was
released on $50,000 bond no cheating
well what ended up happening here is
that one afternoon he was seen leaving
his home in a pickup truck and so like I
guess like the cops got a tip about it
and they also included pictures of a
meth lab in this home and so that's when
Craig when he was leaving he got pulled
over he acknowledged to the police
officer that he had met inside a pipe in
the center console of the truck but then
he also told the officers that he was
making a healthy meth substance that had
acai berry hmm why this for revealing so
much organic man yeah I thought you
would have got in trouble if he just he
would have got in tow for the low
Matthew but this ie met by the way I've
been jacking off to my cousin to just
don't tell her give it up [ __ ] for no
reason no telling it oh I got that
- and well after I got it cuz right
before this you guys didn't see this but
we were talking about you're gonna yeah
the context matters like I was playing
the guy I got it I loved it I got it a
little late but I got it yeah I think is
it the cousin I met the girl cuz she's
so hot she's so funny we all been away
from you guys I well we took it to
cousins now like for real or accuses
insane porn you thought maybe making it
like it would be less of a charge if
it's healthy I don't know I really don't
know his thought process but
investigators did find a very like
substance inside the lab oh they did say
that they they said that no there was no
amount of meth found inside of the
garage but they they believe that he did
have the tools to make about an ounce of
meth a day yeah but that's nothing
nothing science schools have the
material oh hey they didn't find any
meth my brother runs a lab and UCSD and
he could make [ __ ] ounces an ounce of
the method a doesn't make him guilty of
it yeah the name Walter no it's Jeffrey
I call [ __ ] Jeff - I'm like [ __ ]
Jeff guy [ __ ] it he's pleased proud of
my sister yeah so now do you see that as
your brother and now your brother and
your sister I [ __ ] oh yeah are you
jealous also no I'm not jealous I don't
know why you think I'm jealous it's just
cuz he's like shorter than me and stuff
and like weaker than me pick up on that
I probably have a gig from the guy like
what the [ __ ] what is she seeing him I
don't get it yeah [ __ ]
yeah yeah what's his nickname okay
what's his DJ name uh DJ well that's why
do you bring up a Jeff cuz there is a
Jeff in this story deputy chief named
Jeff yeah
culture no white people is to analyze
yeah it would be cool to have like a
diet version or something that is
healthy to Ali's experience it because I
don't want to do math but if they were
like hey this won't kill you as fast or
it's like a hundred times less than real
mess I would try it better less
addictive maybe less yeah I mean I guess
that's why a lot of people like smoking
weed because they're like well that's
mad that's not the same what I do want
to try is maybe a light version of DMT
because DMT sounds so crazy what I get
so transformative and you're like astral
plane and [ __ ] I'm like I don't know if
I'm ready for like that kind of we
obviously listen to the juror experience
probably too much we should be empty
legit I want to I'll be down to it I'll
do with you can we schedule this shaken
oh yes let's do it let's actually do it
let's actually do it it's fine okay
before the year is out we're talking
about that story right now today I want
to do it like a shaman type dude no no
no that's worse that's why you wouldn't
friends because I feel like shamans are
weird you're doing it with your friends
but it's a man is just if someone starts
puking and stuff I want someone else to
play freaking out and this is normal
right if you guys don't do DMT by the
end of the year then you have to do with
you guys I'm not down for that
competition I've gotta get back for
Julie to peg him in the air
oh no you probably wouldn't even be in
your modules going on so that would
probably be the best it might as well
not even be Julia at that point yeah it
could be anybody at least be a girl okay
it fair please all right fine
well what if we anyway barter we down or
what give me that twelve months twelve
not the end of 2020 but twelve months
because half of 2020
no but then that becomes looser you
don't think you can gather up the
courage in six months whoa no I just
have a lot of stuff so I'm serious about
likes what I'm talking about something
I'm actually serious about it and I know
how busy the rest of the year is gonna
be trying to be realistic about but you
also want to improve a life but also
have a kid right me and Jionni because
that mean I promised me and you're gonna
do together for us to leave we need
grandmother come in the picture for
Grandma come the picture she has to be
free from her other response sizes I'm
scheduled to [ __ ] deal you mean okay
okay what we're doing DMT what's the
punishment I don't know I don't know
either you parently get starts like
clockwork elves get there like it's like
I heard it's like being shot out of a
spiritual cannons in the universe like
it's it's a it's a type of psychedelic
death and how do you ingest it's a very
you smoke yeah so it's a very
introspective experience so it's almost
like you like maybe also say like you
only die your life flashes before your
eyes so you get to see all the defense
mechanisms that you've built up for
yourself and really come face to face
with their soul cause you've built your
own identity over the years and now you
get to like kind of smash them all down
and go Who am I really so it's supposed
to be a very introspective feels like
your
I mean like how does again to your city
or small scooter or you drink a tea yeah
so I didn't know you always talk my
ayahuasca I'm potentially down fire
Wasco it's the same thing we don't want
to do a surrender DMT well here check
this out here's what's crazy is she is
like she doesn't do any drugs
yeah but ayahuasca she's potentially
down I think it's the same Shawn out
there that's down he's on the same boat
hmm let's do it
okay that's gonna be interesting I think
safer than alcohol all these things it
does help you obviously with anything
you could use it but like it's not
addictive all these things and then in
some cases legal but I heard it makes
you puke that's what people do other
forms we like it's like God I think you
you scrape you get the jewels of a toad
and use that's different that's natural
that's LSD version things right
EMT are you doing Joe yeah me too
you really are are you afraid that we're
trying to make you do some shady to
ative but I mean like in all honesty I
feel like if we want to involve TIFF we
would have to talk to her she's so
closed off no just because of closed
location please open up with yeah thank
you
oh my god look I'm sure and that if the
right price comes around we can
negotiate that's all I'm saying
you know but now the conversation is
closed because there is no money on the
table we took me to me I'll pay you
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]